signori visto il successo del capolavoro
videoludico chiamato anche streaming ho
deciso di riportare ovviamente allora
ragazzi l'ultima volta era andata molto
bene e ho trovato dan io ero riuscito a
fare paranoid android si chiama di
apprezzare
aspetta aspetta che un attimo che sto
ancora parla stavo discutendo del dico
per la salute è un attimo e la madonna
non ne ho pensavo la russia volta adesso
scontrato con ninja lingiardi sto gioco
questa quella gara serie era caduto
mollare il joystick e fare sul serio
peccato perché sei partito bene adesso
vediamo come va a finire perché tensione
quindi si può si può buttare giù subito
l'avversario dopo che risponda lo faccio
anch'io solo perché l'hai fatto anche tu
infame maledetto comunque l'ultimo
episodio è stato secolare c'è veramente
incredibile sono contento che vi sia
piaciuto così tanto anche perché sono i
giochi che meritano che non mi ha preso
non mi ha preso mai ce l'ha veramente un
po di des treni dove l'avete scritto per
scatto di commenti ma ce l'ha
nello score ma c'era veramente cioè
guardate guardate l'ambientazione è un
po the training effettivamente sincero
ragazzi non ho ancora capito come
funziona per bene perché è visto gioco
il problema è proprio a madonna che
testata da agli ex parà qua e l'ultima
roccia rimasta attenzione meno romeno
perfetto perfetto lo menato più io ed il
who i am e quindi dovrebbe andare giù
stonato giulio prove dominato molto di
più io dicevo non si è ben capito
dicevo non si è ben capito il suo linee
su tendergli uccida vinto attenzione
ma perché i miei pugni valgono di meno
fermi io non ho capito il di il
punteggio come va fatto cioè io sono il
secondo episodio ancora non ho capito
missione come mai eravamo ai
supplementari se mi aveva fatto fuori
molte più volte lui che io
porca vacca che anzi ogni volta che
parte ko ci siamo proprio lui va col
demonio perché ci sono sempre delle
rocce del collini in mezzo porca vacca
che ha lo stesso problema di del
training è difficile prendere alimenti
da ministro gioco kinsey of thieves o o
un'ora un'ora e mezza occhio si sta
risvegliando qua occhio porca vacca
ancora non ho capito come spenderlo
subito che mira stupida oggi va bene è
andata così male pensavo peggio fa ei
whatsapp mancato a me hai preso
effettivamente però non te la data con
ricordi alla roccia zio con il demonio
madonna per un nulla
madonna gioco per un niente manchi
l'avversario per niente guardare ma è
questa
4 preso zio è quanto avevo preso pochi
casi qua mi è preso anche tu
effettivamente con gli occhialini 3d
chiari o in faccia proprio teoricamente
dovrei buttarlo giù i suoi lati a me
buttano giù così parco demonio e non è
possibile è ad ora molla
meno male che l'hai lasciata per terra
della serie 6 un deficiente ritira bravo
aspetta sono stupido e scusami eh ho
voluto provare a vedere se sei se meriti
ma è prova tu ok aspetta che la prendo
vai proviamo è che palle
mi piace che sta al gioco questo qua
grazie stiamo provando a fare questa
cosa da un'ora e mezza allora ti negano
aperte è a posto
e giusto busino a questo gioco devo fare
questo avrei mai pensato nel 2020 2020
signori 2020 2020 ho finito beh se non è
sexy questa cosa ko cosa sta succedendo
ma cos'è ma cos'è la cosa sto vedendo
fai da te lo porto a caso non ho fatto
niente
ti prego aggiungimi e gli amici o voglio
chi sei
ecco va bene io voglio sapere chi sei
lo voglio sapere amico mio spiega mi
spiega l'ing spiegami spiegami dimmi chi
sei voglio conoscerti se sei il mio
migliore amico non so chi tu sia ma se
il mio miglior amico pareggio
ti amo io ti amo fatti vedere dimmi chi
sei ti adoro fantastico ragazzo
bellissimo cioè queste sono le amicizie
che mi dicono che il gioco non ti porta
amicizie guarda guarda guarda braindead
worm ho fatto amicizia con verme senza
cervello
berne cervello morto o finalmente in
questo gioco trovato un po di
interattività che avete presente il meme
tipo instagram facebook
whatsapp pinder eccoti nder sono così
allora sono contro emis killa cos'è ce
l'ho detto solo killah killah nel senso
uccidi ok hai detto tu ce l'ha scritto
nel nome sono già se ne cela il titolo 9
colpa tua che facciamo chi l'ha e lo
tiro l'acqua di un altro molto mancato
in tutti e due poi possiamo cambiare
gioco si chiama loket league dove è
andato lo zero ma no sono morto
sono morto ma fatto hanno fatto ma fatto
hanno fatto un fatto che ha fatto una
faccia ti fa mi fa mi fanno parte gli fa
mi è mancato tantissimo
ahia ahia ahia ahia ma dai
per niente però mm diluvio che tiro
bellissimo era un tiro bellissimo
ragazzi peccato peccato let's go home è
la madonna che mira bruta dunque col
fatto che ti giri è proprio una un
tempismo diversissimo veramente ragazzi
madonna quanto sei meritato ragazzi è
veramente molto più difficile di quello
che sembra so già come lo giuro è
difficilissimo anche se vedi doveva la
roccia vi giuro che non è per niente
facile
spero che mia madre non mi vedo giocare
a sta roba perché non saprei spiegarlo
grazie finalmente due ore e mezza
adesso risponde riley
quindi prova a no dovete ed è sparato
chi non è sposato ma di tirami 6
coraggio tirami bravo ha il coraggio
l'importante è avere coraggio pareggio
pareggio ormai tanto sono abituata a
fare già visto gioco anche se non ho
capito come si fa il pareggio mi si
perde così dice va bene
next ci siamo già partiti bahamas con
questa bella bella plain è uno ore spa
nacua forse no si lavora giorno
pensiamo ai mataj questo era proprio
brutto questo è proprio è bellissima
perché plain non c'è neanche un ostacolo
ma dai ma dai
per una volta che ho sparato un po più
distante del solito dai o dio ti
ringrazio
ok ora voglio provare a spoon kilar lo
se riesco ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta
vedete che si può sfanculare è un po
strano il suo gioco dovrebbero averlo
tolto stanchi devi darti almeno un
secondo di di invulnerabilità perché uno
vede dove sta suonando l'altro capito
quindi bastati dalla roccia un po prima
non è proprio il massimo ma che avevano
sfilato prima grazie tyco è stato preso
in cui è stato preso zero cioè cartelle
comunque ragazzi paus non vuol dire
pugno perchè hai scritto sbai sit com 11
punti wen ch vuol dire pugno pound ci
vuol dire pancia che la tullow pronuncio
sbagliato penso si pronunci pong o che
siamo su pancia non pugno teoricamente e
si vede
l'ho ammazzato praticamente sono io sta
partita scommetti che c'era da parità
bravo è bravo sono stato qua e là che
espone in quelli in mano con la prima
vanno lette dai dati e l'ultima crociata
per sparare solo qui si può sfondare in
mano no bellissimo sono stato un
fenomeno e quindi si parla solo la è
solo quella alla luce rimanente sudan
dance
abbiamo capito però l'ho fatto fuori
sempre io ci manca solo che vince lui
c'è questo non me lo potevano andare non
ha fatti non ha fatto niente dall'isola
che se vi faceva pareggiare anche questo
me lo andavo che ho fatto tutto io
rega suoli a beh questa era pound pancia
questo era pancia il 2020 lo apprezzo lo
apprezzo non ho capito vi sia piaciuto
iscriviti al canale si esce dalla
campanellina prima della giornata i suoi
video e noi come sempre ci vediamo a
questo episodio bella ragazza
[Musica]